we're gonna get ready to begin thank you
all for staying so long it's been a long
and very exciting two days and we're
going to begin our final panel
discussion liminal places cultures and
powers here there why should we care
that rhyme implications for politics
research and pedagogies I think that
we'll start off by introducing our new
panelists we have Leo Vasquez professor
at the blasting school of planning and
public policy at Rutgers University he
is well regarded for his expertise on
diversity in the planning profession he
is a founder of planners for ethics and
cultural diversity the largest group of
its kind in the planning profession and
a founder of Latinas and planning a
network of more than 200 Planning and
Community Development professionals so
that's very exciting we are also
privileged to have good in a frenzy
scope with Davey assistant professor
from New York University he's a
sociologist by training and holds
intellectual interests in the area of
local labor markets gentrification
raised admits ethnicity in the United
States his courses include urban space
and resistance mapping for social change
Latinos in the politics race in the
United States and gentrification and its
discontents he is currently doing a
research on undocumented Latino workers
and the social regulation of local labor
markets were also welcoming back our
earlier panel moderators thomann Gotti
from Hunter College um quote hail data
files from here at Columbia University
and Tatiana shore um who I actually
don't know where she comes from so from
the federal university of Amazonas so we
are really excited over the past two
days we've been extremely lucky to share
a diverse range of research about
emergent transnational relationships and
identities from art exhibitions in New
York to mega projects and X
Mexico to public spaces in Barcelona to
music subcultures in Japan this
conference has illuminated for us the
importance and breadth of transnational
Latin American isms but the question
really here which claddagh alluded to
earlier in our previous panel is so what
that is after all we've learned about
all these interesting and complex case
studies presented in these two days at
the conference what are some of the
first thoughts that the panelists might
comment on that come to their minds as a
compliment employed the implications for
politics research or pedagogy so I would
like each of you to take about two
minutes thank you sure what are some of
the it's a very open-ended question what
are some of the first thoughts that come
to your mind as you contemplate
implications for politics research and
pedagogies in transnational Latin
American isms based on the papers that
we heard or otherwise is anybody ready
to be good two minutes to think okay
okay well guess home okay I'll start
this off can everybody hear me or do it
do I need the microphone microphone Oh
using the microphone because we're
recording okay well just to let you know
a little bit about where my perspective
is coming from Latinos and planning is
the largest organization of planners it
focused on planning in Latino
communities and most of our members are
latina themselves although not all of
them and we've heard a number of over
the past three years we conducted a
number of dl arose where we want it we
asked planners specifically what are the
biggest planning challenges facing
Latino communities and
the two biggest planning challenges
relate to public participation of
Latinos in the planning process and the
second one is about the way planners
engage with Latino communities now and I
think one of the what the growth of
transnational communities in the United
States does is it really creates almost
an existential challenge for the
planning profession about how planners
do their work which traditionally has
been focused on regulating land uses
really a management mindset working with
transnational communities requires being
more open to diversity quite frankly
more open to chaos and tension that
occurs when you have multi multiple
communities and then the integration of
those multi multiple communities
creating really new sub communities
because people have multiple identities
as they as they move in their lives and
they live in another place so I think
the the challenge is one of the
challenges is how planners work with
Latino communities how planners think
about what their job is and I think the
challenge is going to be not just
thinking about regulating land use which
has had certain failures but thinking
about how do you integrate how do you
value difference how do you make it work
within regulatory structures that for
the most part are focused on still
focused on segregation and restrictions
of land uses the other thing that I
would say is focus on economic
development what transnational
communities do is really they are a key
to globalization and where this really
has an impact on the ground is in
in the uses of commercial space
specifically i would say industrial
space and warehousing space now i live
and work in new jersey and we have a lot
of older smaller industrial spaces that
many of them are being converted into
either residential or retail spaces yet
many of those spaces could very well be
used and are being used as avenues for
for import export for example a commute
an ethnic community brings in raw
materials into Port Newark it gets
shipped over into a what's considered an
obsolete industrial warehousing facility
they those parts get assembled and then
they get sold in those ethnic
communities so one of the keys there the
lesson there is protecting those older
industrial spaces even though we are led
to believe that they would be better off
being converted into housing retail of
loss etc and learn more than two minutes
I can't be the only one speak
okay so this way the two planners will
do our thing and then other folks get in
I I really appreciate the tenor of the
panels to in in the way that they deal
with the complexity of issues and the
ambiguity of public spaces and I think
this is something that's very important
in an interdisciplinary conference and
discussion and in a Trenton
transnational environments so I think
this is really important an important
lesson that I got from the listening to
the discussions today the but I'm
looking for some more clarity and I
think it's necessary to at the risk of
being called structuralist or
determinist or narrow look for
determination and I felt a relief when I
heard today sigh say in the last panel
that labor and capital were involved and
that the mobility of labor and capital
had a good deal to do and help to
explain the complexities and ambiguities
of what we're talking about there is
also a tendency in my profession and in
among architects and those who deal with
the physical environment to be physical
determinists and to place the physical
environment over economic relations or
social relations and and I and I would I
would I would say that neither solely
and economic or a physical view
by itself is helpful but we need to go
deeper I think and look at the
connections I thought the case of class
of Mexico was actually very telling
because it showed how little the
physical design of the space was
determining the social use the actual
use of the space that to me seemed to be
one of the most important lessons and it
affects our discussions about the
preservation of urban spaces too much we
in the design professions pretend that
our designs shape human relations when
in practice we have a lot to learn about
how human relations shape the form of
public spaces and for the forms of form
of cities I and and you know when I hear
finally somebody mentioned NAFTA how to
explain the flows of labor and capital
without NAFTA and the dramatic changes
that occur both in Mexico in the United
States and they're occurring in every
country in Latin America as the result
of free trade because it's been on a
very unequal a process where capital has
had all the freedom and labour has had
very little where labor gets stopped at
the border so when you talk about
bounded tourism what you explain that by
not that because NAFTA the whole idea of
doctor was complete freedom for capital
almost complete and restriction of the
movements of labor also I think it's
that there's one thing missing in the
discussion
of what's going on in the United States
and Latino communities in the United
States and that is the long and this is
what's happening in in academia
especially is the long historical
theoretical debate between assimilation
ISM and transnationalism for want of a
better term assimilate similar the
assimilationist approach has dominated
the idea of the melting pot right from
the beginning and I don't think you
begin to understand the the bounded
transnationalism until you understand
the extent to which the assimilation is
politics actually even in new york city
a city which is quite diverse has people
from nationalities all over the world
and despite the fact that Spanish is
spoken everywhere there are children in
New York City Schools who will be
disciplined for speaking Spanish their
children in new york city schools who
are disciplined for speaking Arabic us
the the dominant now let's say genomic
no imminent atomic I'm sorry is is still
English monolingual and monocultural the
standard is still the monocultural
standard and and that's what that's what
the US and Mexico and the u.s. in Latin
America means it doesn't just mean
American culture it's the monoculture
and then I will end with the one one
last question that occurred to me during
the discussion which i think would open
me an interesting discussion is can you
imagine ever walmart doing something
like plaza mexico that says something
about the freedom of global capital and
the monoculture of gold
capital and how it is is shaping
cities throughout the world thank you
thinking about pedagogical and research
agendas I tend to agree with planner I
think it's time that we take from the
Latin American Studies or the Brazilian
studies the thematic of Latin American
ISM and let it permeate all other
disciplines especially in my case when
we study urbanization it is very
important to understand how it is so in
turand into the urban tissue that it
cannot be separated as something
different from the whole of the city as
the plaza mexico example said it tells
us much more about la then about what is
in fact Mexican culture or Mexican
heritage is being reinterpreted by
transnational also what Clara said about
mutti cited a research i think is very
interesting because it is a time that we
should see a little bit more of
ping-ponging not only of the influence
of latin american isms with relation to
the US but also Latin American ISM in
Latin America and then we should the the
talk about the Bolivians in some foul
the Bolivians in Buenos Aires or the
Colombian doctors which occupy all the
medical posts in the sodium oh he's in
the Amazon we don't have Brazilian
doctors we have Colombian and Peruvian
doctors and how do these all relate with
the trafficking of humans through the
Amazon up Venezuela and to Spain and how
does this relate to the Spanish woman
with all the work we saw about Latin
American woman living by themselves in
cities like my dream with comparison to
the Moroccan woman which live with their
families and how can we interpret eight
these fluxes in a much
more dynamic transnational perspective I
think a possible agenda could include
these themes and I think also that there
is pointed out something interesting is
a bit of sociology of science of what
are the Latin American academics which
are now in the US now be them native
Latin Americans be them Americans in
general what have they been studying how
has it been organized and what are the
themes that have appeared in last 2025
years maybe 30 years and how do these
how do these the mattox lead to
different directions and discussion
which could be more open to other
disciplines which are not specifically
Latin American study like planning well
I thought it was a fabulous conference I
had a great time listening to all the
papers and my brain was stimulated
continuously I mean without caffeine
actually I was I was doing pretty well
just with the presentations which is you
know quite amazing for a two-day
conference where you you know it's hard
to keep up and in terms of pedagogy you
know I thought that it was if this is
really quite quite relevant to what's
happening in universities today where
the question of interdisciplinarity was
so important you know at one point began
in the humanities and all of a sudden
the money that the sciences have begun
to realize that the only way to advance
science is to really begin to work
across departments now the universities
are in a sense waking up to the idea of
interdisciplinary in a serious way and
funding it and so you're seeing in a
sense schools i would say falling apart
we're being restructured by the setup of
institutions that are drawing professors
from different fields in order to try to
address certain problems and they're you
know they're creating institutes or you
know research facilities of swords and
the real question is what is relevant
what are the relevant problems of our
day and what are relevant questions you
know what is the relevant knowledge that
we need to bring to the table in order
to address those problems and certainly
it seems to me that this is one of the
major issues of our day is this problem
of globalization and transnational
realities in this problem precisely of
capital versus labor freedom but also I
think that one of the things that we
have come to realize during the doing
the presentations is that we can we have
to rethink ourselves as academics we
have to rethink our own disciplines I'm
working with an historic preservation we
have to really begin to kind of go to
square one in a sense historic
preservation works on the assumption
that the way that one regulates the
historic environment is based on notions
of stylistic integrity you know this is
the way we kind of come to decisions as
to what is valuable or not I mean these
are obsolete terms we can continue to
function in this way if we are really to
take seriously the learnings that that
we are kind of engaging in conferences
like this because if let's say only
capital circulates and as you know
gayatri spivak is fond of saying that's
only in capital circulates and the rest
is damage control then some of the kinds
of damage control that we do as
academics is more damage than anything
you know is it contributing to the
damage so in rethinking our disciplines
I think that we would need to not fall
back on the post-war model of a kind of
extended multiculturalism you know which
is the
and I maybe that's a little bit what I
was hearing on when you were saying I
kind of we cannot be monoculture we have
that I don't omit item with that maybe I
asked you the class like that i but i
think we are on the same page on that
but I I think that we cannot do we
cannot follow the model of this kind of
extended multiculturalism and really
rethink ourselves in different terms I
don't know what those terms might be it
might be the transnational although that
is a term that has its own history but I
think the implications for pedagogy is
that in teaching our classes we need to
really begin to break down certain
boundaries that have been created in the
University in order to solve previous
problems so preservation was formed for
example as an academic discipline as a
way to solve problems that are not
necessarily here anymore and so we're
still kind of producing solutions to a
problem that is obsolete so we're
creating the problem in order to solve
it in some ways and so to try to bring
in I think we need to and I and it's
hard to do that because people are
tenured and you know you you know how do
you bring in new people you know will
add jumps our way to you know new new
lines and so on but creating I think
arrangements by virtue of which we can
have access to to each other's knowledge
is important the first steps is our
conferences like this where we actually
sit down in a room and listen to what
other people are doing very rarely with
somebody in preservation listen to
somebody in geography or anthropology
and likewise I think very rarely with an
anthropologist give a preservationist 20
minutes of their time so this is you
know already quite important I think the
next step is to is to list it is to do
joint projects you know joint academic
projects joints to do projects in which
we challenge each other and it would
seem to me that that each of the papers
that were
were presented our lend themselves to be
really incredible academic exercise and
we saw some already you know Rosetta
Drita's project that that was an
excellent one in which you know the
students were really beginning to
confront these issues and I think maybe
the kind of larger theme there is also
what has happened to the public sphere
in terms of these questions you know
because part of the issue that we talked
about in thinking what role do cities
play in the public sphere what role do
the media networks play in the public
sphere what role does the internet plan
the public sphere I think that you know
I'm thinking back of hannah arendt
notion of the public spheres are kind of
based on speech acts and communication
you know how to I think a lot of what we
saw was a types of public spheres that
were not necessarily based on speech
acts that were based on performative
actions and so on that worked it more
difficult to analyze and more difficult
to understand because nobody's
verbalizing them and so a lot of the
task of the the intellectual work that
is happening here is to begin to be able
to express that in a in a way that is
that helps us that are outside of those
practices in a sense we can to
understand them and see how they can
translate so I guess you know I don't
have a clear and what I just you know I
think it's a kind of it's a process
whereby you know I the institutions that
we work in today the universities are
somehow in the way of our ability to do
this kind of work because of yeah irony
yes thank you
I want to say thank you for the lemon
said were saying thank you for the
opportunity to to participate and to
think Clara for putting this this very
energizing and interesting conference
together what I would like to highlight
then is some of the political
implications that came to mind as I as I
listened to some of the presentations
away and now want to do that through a
triangulation so so in the one hand we
have this wealth of transnational Latino
migration and we had a chance to look at
different many permutations but I want
to counter pose some of our points today
with I want to highlight the notion of
the state also you know this the
transnational Latino migration visa V
the role of the state and someone asked
earlier which is like a very sharp
question you know can is it fair to say
like the label immigrant like the
category immigrants that should be
useless you know we want to also it
could ask the question is to term latina
also you know uses like at the end of
the day you know we're really dealing
with human beings trying to make ends
meet and so and support the when you
turn on the states which you know as I
said let you know and then then we start
to see that you saw that people start to
getting round up or like targeted for
state repression because of where they
come from or the language they speak or
like the racial profiling and so on so
to me the answer to the question is are
these terms irrelevant or not you know
well there's a way which they are very
relevant in terms of the politics of
language and and the way we label
certain populations so and that doesn't
take away from the individual aspect of
like you know like there's is this of
the stuff going on but it gets the point
of rains cloud on earlier which is
making their point it is both ways
there's a way in which this labels are
not necessarily useful in accounting for
this other stuff but there's a way in
which we must understand the role of the
state in racial icing Latinos and now so
which is for me that transition from
Latin America to Latinos it is mediated
by the state is to stay that racialized
these populations by labeling them and
targeted them both in terms of
repression and in terms of positive
reinforcement and so on so I just want
to highlight the role of the state but i
also want to and and more importantly
for me it's the this conversation is
happening against the background of
invisibility there's a way in which
latinos are very much invisible in the
US public imagination and i always like
to use the example of a movie that came
out a few years ago what's called the
day after tomorrow how many people have
seen a decent movie about like some
tsunami-like destroy it's like new york
city like in 2003 or somewhere so when i
saw that movie I'm like that's
impossible yeah that could never happen
and my friends are like no no global
warming it was actually i'ma like I have
no problems with this tsunami like I can
see this number my question is how could
you have the end of the world in New
York City and no see any light of
Latinos and I saw a scissors you get a
very wide movie instead of the show
which of course is don't think of
looking at you you will be here they I
just me oh you know the running back and
forth but but for me this is actually an
example of popular culture that we
actually takes the pulse of where the
Latino
our visa being this broader background
of mainstream society that needs to be
so this is the triangulation that I want
to post as a way to sort of highlight
what are the political challenges for
for this research of transnational
migration and what are the implications
and they want to have like two more
question areas of conflict and
challenges in which Latinos profoundly
disrupt our understanding of American
identity you know is this is this is
there there's a very quantitative aspect
to end just a sheer numbers but there's
also a deeper aspect that actually that
the question of transnational and
migration points at the forefront of the
conversation and and we have this a
schizophrenia of migration policy in the
US where like on the one hand we have to
let undocumented labor into the country
because otherwise the economy cannot
survive and this is this is accepted
both on the left and the right but at
the same time we have to criminalize
them because it isn't that ordering that
we get to define ourselves as American
so we are not like those people over
there who like Ensenada eyes and you
know the one speak English and so on so
forth so this is the tensions to me that
I want to sort of highlight through this
conversation of transnationalism so what
does it mean because when you look at
the Megamart in 2006 okay so you get
this dialectics like into one hand you
see this incredible examples of
solidarity and social movements that are
go hand in hand with this incredible
increase in a state repression and
anti-immigrant sentiment and to me this
is the head-on collision that we have to
find a way to deal with in terms of
research in terms of pedagogy and
teaching but also politically under
and they hope like this and so thank you
for this kind of spaces because we need
more of it so thank you much soon thank
you so much to all of you I think that
in the last couple of minutes a lot of
really important questions have been
raised I think in the spirit of making
this more of an open discussion we're
going to open it up to the audience
bearing in mind that our panelists have
emphasized the use of transdisciplinary
alliances to address our commitment to
social and spatial inclusion in what
we've sort of framed as the just City or
our vision of the just City so some
really important new issues have been
raised I think it would be great if we
had some more dialogue from new people I
know a lot of people have been sitting
here for a few days then they probably
have a lot of questions a lot of the
panels unfortunately didn't allow so
much time for discussion so I will take
questions whenever you start raising
your hands yeah Marcella yeah I would
like to ask a professor ungodly a little
bit about what you started to say about
/ determinism yeah and I think that it
also touches on something that we were
talking about with renee and this is the
question that applies for all of us who
are trying to think about the programs
that have been discussed during today's
here what are the theoretical frameworks
upon which we are trying to approach
these problems that i agree with Clara
are almost the same that we keep phasing
and how can we make a call for a
stronger theoretical reflection and I
think of our determinism comes into into
into the question of of us it's a
central point into that theoretical
reflection it so that your minimal power
is over determinism of
capital or economic factors is wood so I
wanted to ask you a little bit because
you said well in the past we used to
fold into the / determinism zuv economic
figures and yes there are here but we
probably agree that we are not over
determind of that it's it's a very much
trendy to speak about / determinism of
power structures I don't know really I I
probably would like to ask some of you
what about that I just clarify I think I
never used the term / determinism I I'm
I think it's important politically if we
as scholars are going to intervene in
the real world in a political world with
social movements with political
movements we're dealing with questions
of immigration dealing with questions of
public space and in various struggles
all over that once we've overanalyzed
something which we always do as
intellectuals we have to step back and
say what are the political questions and
how can we clarify what's going on and
at a certain point we have to we have to
make some determinations ourselves
what's most important what is actually
occurring in the phenomena that we're
looking at because we have to interpret
it in a way that people can use it so if
people are struggling over the use of
space you know there are invariably
determined determining factors and I
think one of the unfortunate one of the
positive aspects of post-modernism
is it helped to break down some of the
old struck the old cobwebs of
structuralism but one of the negative
things was it left out determination
entirely and you can never conclude
anything and I'm sorry if you if you're
involved in any political struggles you
don't have the luxury of endless
circular reasoning and discussing the
complexities and going around in circles
people have to make decisions about what
to do and that's basically it's politics
you have to do you have to decide what
to do and you have to make decisions
about what are the most important
factors what are the priorities and and
that's why I think economics and
politics are often the determining
factors they determine much about our
socialize but not everything and that
was the that was the problem with
extreme structuralism of course that it
through everything else out and said
that there's only one determinant but
but you know bottom line is and this is
what and we have to be able to have
these conversations with people across
languages and cross cultures will also
have different concepts of what
determination is or even don't even have
a concept of determination you know so
if you look at the dialogues in the
world Social Forum this is one of the
problems between European philosophy and
other philosophies in the world so I
think we have uh but if we think about
it politically it helps to clarify well
I mean I think that for
but my fella brought a really
interesting point yesterday precisely on
this that it's certainly I mean what
part of the the work that we do is
analyze situations and sometimes we find
double bindings but that in the notion
of strategic essentialism is one that
takes into account our knowledge of the
full complexity of situation and yet
allows us to act without in full
consciousness of what we're doing and
sometimes precisely to make allegiances
that were unsuspected in some way in the
purpose of trying to get something
accomplished or in the process of gets
get something accomplished but then
allows us also to reconstitute more
let's say equitable political sphere
after that goal has been accomplished
and maybe rethink and move outside of
the strategic essentialism once that has
been when once that particular goal has
been accomplished so I think that you
know some some let's say some some way
some openings were made in that
direction what I think is also very
interesting about what you were saying
is that that's that strategic
essentialism has not bottom-up and for
the sometimes for the in the in the best
interest of a just society but that
sometimes the state simply essential
eise's and racial eise's and those are
two different realities and two
different processes and somehow our role
is to begin to distinguish them and to
take them apart
well I think related to those comments
for those of when we're looking at the
policy professions whether they be
planning the design professions historic
preservation etc I think the challenge
is to move from a management mindset to
more of a leadership might say in denim
but that I mean that the management
mindset is focused on managing
complexity and and that leads to the the
oversimplification of the other the the
leadership mindset is about managing
change and being open to to diversity is
being open to basically allowing for for
change to happen in letting that be okay
one of the things that we have as I
think one of the challenges in the
design professions is everything is so
programmed you know our focus is is on
programming uses whether it's in
architectural what or economics and so
what we've seen in some examples that we
talked about is that you really can't
program uses that that the youth the
best uses grow organically but of course
the route the real politic here is you
can't just say to elected officials well
let's just put it out there and see what
happens there has to be some direction
so that I think is the key challenge and
I agree that the only way it's going to
really happen is through an
interdisciplinary approach where people
from different professions are
challenged to think in different ways
about the same problems thank you I
think that we might be ready to move on
to a new question if there's one
I'm taking the occasion to thank Lucia
for a great job with the reservation of
the hotels and everything and for
passing me the microphone actually it's
interesting to me to see that in order
to hear about Latin American I had to
take an international class so that
relates a little bit to your comment
about the day after so it's it's unreal
but my question is really why planners
are not really more exposed to the real
life and it's a little bit I guess but
the professor gussain before we hear
about all these theories and everything
that that needs to be done and we know
what needs to be done but then when
immigration issues happen and people are
on the streets marching and and the
actual issues are out there why the
conversation is not really happening at
the municipal levels at the level where
people can be really educated and not
wait for crisis
just just what on the previous question
um I wonder to what extent we have
removed the politics out of our
professional practice and I'm
particularly talking about planning and
in an effort to gain professional
recognition we have moved to a
technocratic domain that takes the
politics out of our planning practices
and to what extent that it's even
embedded in our event in an academic
domain this is a particular reality what
we have here we have broken a bunch of
boundaries we are engaged and very loose
about how we listen to each other and I
really appreciate the comments that the
panel made about that openness which
doesn't happen every day but as it was
pointed out we function within
institutions where you're supposed to
respond to very specific theoretical
constructs within your field and you get
a specific points for the publications
that you get within a specific journals
so those challenges are huge and not
only as scholars who are trying to
produce and function in academia but the
way we translate that then to the
students and the way the students not
about what they learn but what they end
up losing by navigating our academic
domains and I wondered to what extent
then this depolarization is not just in
a planning practice but to some extent
within our academic domain which ends up
constraining this kind of very fruitful
that dialogue but that doesn't happen
it's not common in our intellectual
domains
hi my question would be very different
it seems that to talk about
transnationalism we have talked most of
the time about local places like about
local case studies and somehow I had the
intuitive aim to have found about an
analysis that or to talk about policies
or advocacy that has to enact that has
to act in two places at the same time so
it's chance nationalize it because in
many of the cases seems that for a given
case study there should be something
done there so that is a kind of national
policy that acts transnationally in a
national territory and the idea of
acting transnationally and makes me
think that if it is possible to think
about trans national policy in planning
any feet if it is possible how would
that differ from international planning
policy I think we'll probably take a
moment to answer those questions for we
move on so probably let's start with the
first tuba theory and practice questions
whoever wants to answer than the minimum
move on to alejandros okay to have
something to say well you just ask the
right question for me this is I face
this daily I teach in a university and I
feel that I'm surrounded by people who
use interdisciplinarity all the time and
talk about it but when I go out and do
it I'm the first to get hit over the
head okay secondly people also talk
about practice all the time and
integrating theory and practice and I go
out and do it and I pay for it so our
institution
are hypocritical into I find
interdisciplinarity to be actually on
the wane we lost our Latin American
Studies program as an other program
other Latin American Studies is is
dwindling I thought nationally and and I
think it is true when I think it is
unfortunate that you have to take
international planning in the United
States I find this an incredible we have
a discussion going on in our department
now about whether to create
International Studies concentration and
I'm sorry I disrupted the whole faculty
meeting when I said I don't know what
the hell you're talking about what is
international what isn't international
and in New York City in the most
powerful country in the world what isn't
international and I think it goes back
to this this idea I think I what I was
talking about multiculturalism what I
really meant to say was multiculturalism
has become the International branding
for free US Capitol around the world we
are a multicultural Empire and so our
cities have a multicultural face but
it's all it's all disney world you know
epcot center it's all it's all a
performance put on with the exterior
qualities of cultures that has very
little to do with the essence of the
cultures and the people in the culture
is also and just look at the 2012
Olympics in New York City the way it was
branded and the publicity around it it
was the assimilationist dream this
wonderful melting pot of happy people
from all over the world who lived in
harmonies who joined arms and sang
kumbaya I live in New York
that that's not what that's not the way
the city works okay so I I think I think
we have a lot to do and and by swimming
against the current though within our
academies and outside and and I guess
the last thing that relates to the last
question because maybe then I won't
comment on that is how to deal with
trans nationality I think the question
that has to be asked first of all is
who's trans nationality transnational
what labor capital culture what are we
talking about everything moves
everything is part of global networks
but not all trans nationalities are the
same quarry the mean sir so one of the
questions that I here instead of posting
in this event is a question is the
production of transnational urban space
The Da Vinci Code you know that it's
going to solve this riddle of how do we
do politics you know local the politics
of knowledge production and and and you
know and I just I just want to to
highlight that you know like this is one
of the themes that I hear like you know
can we what would that look like if if
in fact the claims that we're making our
accurate and so on I do also want to
make like a what I have like Liam would
active as a friendly amendment when you
say like change will only happen with
interdisciplinary collaborations but I
don't want to lose track of the
political aspect of this discipline sec
you know sort of like when you look at
the history of ethnic studies in fact is
comes out of like struggles of students
shoving down campuses so and and this is
to me one of the virtues of critical
theory you know
whatever permutation of flavor you want
to use with this but it is pro limit
icing the knowledge production with the
agents producing it and how they're
implicated in that very framework so so
I guess I'm a friendly amendment to you
to the vision of interdisciplinary
collaboration is it has to be supported
by by some kind of politics at the end
of the day this departments are not it's
not a question of brilliant papers back
and forth and and and I'm all enough
that I remember when when some of those
fights were going on and and now with
rice intuition across the nation I I
think it's fair to assume we're going to
see another generation of student social
movements fighting for further education
and so on so forth but i but i do know
what a lose track of the political
aspect that is embedded in part in the
very concept of knowledge prevention and
injustice and just to add to that I
think it's the first question about why
aren't plan is more educated about these
issues I think because planners in
general and planning academic academics
aren't challenged either by students
because our planning schools are quite
frankly very homogenous only about seven
now I haven't looked at the latest acsp
figures association of Collegiate
Schools of planning but only in the 2008
numbers only about seven percent of the
student population and pliant schools
was Latino how many Latinos do you know
of that are executives of planning firms
how many can you name that that run
planning firms that run planning
organizations in New York in the New
York area which has the most diverse
labor pool in perhaps in the country
except for maybe Los Angeles continued
in so there's not that challenge either
from the employers or the students and I
think this is going to continue because
the and this is a continuing on the
credits
appliance course is that the traditional
planning curriculum of the full time
daytime program which I know there are
programs that aren't tends to be biased
towards people with wealth and time
which means that the extent that that's
correlated with with race and income it
means that the you're going to have
greater marginality in your planning
schools the other thing about removing
politics I think the reason is and this
goes back to the plant to the heuristics
of planning to the mindset the planning
whether its organizational planning
urban planning is all about managing
risk and we do see risk that's that's
why you plan immigrants the other in
quote is risk so as you know thumb said
one way you could do it deal with it is
to Disney Phi them as it's done in
astoria with Greek communities with
little lily and if they're not
Disneyfied then they're scary like an
oyster bay where they they produce
regulations that I think that I forget
what the official name is but it's
locally known as well waving wild latino
so this gets into and and the issue of
politics what happens is planners wind
up falling back into using racially
neutral language technocratic language
because in many cases it's disturbing to
deal with the challenges deal with the
risks of of immigration of dealing
dealing with the other and as we've seen
time and time again whether it's with a
supermarket in Orange County where a
where a Latino theme supermarket was
denied an application while a more
generic anglicized supermarket or in the
map or a mountain laurel
in New Jersey wear racially neutral
language was used effectively to prevent
african-americans for moving to the
community we see that time and time
again and what happens is i think many
planets because they're not challenged
in their own schools and their own
training they do not become a lot of
them do not become reflective enough to
say wait a second you know I'm a good
hard person I'm a good progressive yet
the actions I take the work I do seems
to perpetuate institutional racism thank
you we have about five minutes left so
I'm gonna ask if you have any more
questions there's a question did no but
there was another question wasn't it the
trench ya allah see ya tional policy so
well okay should we combine questions ok
do you want to address the question now
oh no no what I think I was just saying
that there was any question about
national pie the different levels of
halsey do you want to ask her a question
yeah I'm not sure how to ask it i'm
trying to think about a number of the
comments that have been made but i'm
really interested in the places where we
can't fuse let you know in Latin
American Studies very easily and I think
it draws upon some of the comments that
were made I think you know if we think
about Latino Studies and ethnic studies
they definitely emerged out of critical
social movements in Latin American
Studies area studies that came out of
the cold war and these are very
different formations and I think I've
had very very different histories and
I'm really struck by this comment of the
dissolution of Latin American Studies
precisely at the time where you see more
queer critical theorists more people of
color doing an engaging race and a lot
of the the important critical theory
work that has been done and using that
from Latino Studies and really
implementing that in Latin American
Studies you see that at lesson why is it
now that this is dissolving right so
these kinds of articulations but I also
think that there's something about this
question that spills out into kind of
question of public space I mean I
think that the containment of knowledge
and I do see a reaction in disciplines
I'm you know trained as a sociologist
and there's a real reactionary strand
towards interdisciplinarity there again
precisely at the time where we're making
inroads and kind of creative political
thinking and engagement I think it's
analogous in some ways to this
management of capital of spaces but I am
heartened by the comment that I think we
will see and reaction to the dismantling
of something like the UC system or you
know kind of real engage social
movements that spill out and exceed and
I think that's true of public space I
mean a lot of it the spaces of
segregation are they bleed in certain
places so it's not really I mean I'm
trying to call together this and think
through where we can actually learn from
the kind of questions and coupling of
knowledge and power the kind of
racialization practices that are you
know done and carried out by the state
and how this is somehow says something
about the work of planning and I guess
you know I think there's some overlap I
just don't know how to put it all
together thank you I'll take one more
and I think that's going to be our last
well I think just so briefly comment on
that I think there's an opportunity
there to do in the dissolution of Latino
Studies there might be an opportunity to
to create a different sort of
pedagogical reality within departments
that doesn't relegate Latino Studies to
one person because usually what happens
is you know oh boy we're going to get
accredited and we really need to fill
this check mark here that deals with you
know either what could be latina but I
don't know that the planners have the
Latino check mark but but it's but it's
probably non-western
I have a non-western check mark and then
it's a and then it's we need to hire
somebody in this line so immediately the
entire faculty gets kind of exempt from
the need to actually think about the
problem and to re-educate themselves and
there's a kind of tokenism that takes
place you know this this is the
non-western person this is the Latino
Studies person or whatever so if there
is a kind of you know reorganization of
the University in the sense that the
certain departments are getting cut out
then you know it's an opportunity also
to make claims for the re-education of
you know entire faculties I mean because
ultimately that's what's at stake it
seems to me you know and so there would
have to be more teacher training
seminars conferences that deal with you
know how do you teach your subject in a
way that it incorporates you know some
of the theoretical contributions that
latino studies have made to the field so
that it you know you see what I mean
that that would be I know I know that
sounds kind of like an impossibility but
there might be an opportunity there to
make that claim
think that when we're talking about
transnationalism I would like to I like
the idea of the Latino centers being
dispersed and entering other areas that
might have other implications like
practical implication to how the studies
of Latin America or Brazil with all its
complications happen and us but at the
same time I'm much more interested in
knowing for example what is happening to
the transportation system in the back on
base and then how can I compare that to
the transportation system in the Amazon
basin with but you know in the minute
and then and think about a more
transnational comparative world in which
we could see political spheres which
don't only segregate all these are the
Latino and the Latino have to talk about
on America and the Asians about the age
and everybody like talks with the
Western European and US to ask well
where should we go that's one aspect of
bilateralism that that needs to be put
into question and at the same time what
you've taught said and he says that
there is still this monoculture even
though and very strongly and
invisibility is incredible how you have
schools are a very good example because
they're in New York City they're
extremely diverse but the teachers are
all America and they're not prepared to
understand diversity no poor teachers
but and and the political sphere with
the sensation we have here in the US
that political sphere after nine eleven
and all the consequences it has to be
refound somewhere you know i'm waiting
for riots about the g train that
bloomberg is gonna close and i haven't
seen the riots it's like come on high
school kids aren't you gonna break the
trains you know it's not that you should
but where are the riots like she only
had a big I don't know what happened
yesterday yesterday
what how is the political sphere gonna
be refound or political not governmental
public sphere refounded well the the
rally at Hunter College against the
cutbacks at CUNY was very lively
yesterday but it was also very
frightening to see the police presence
for the first time post 9-11 you begin
to see the challenges ahead I actually
think your question you know about how
actually interdisciplinary studies and
the demand for faculties to break out of
their disciplinary silos came from
student protests from the 1960s and 70s
it came from the civil rights movement
the peace movement and and their
presence on campuses and that's where I
would put my hope that there's there are
people who are more able to and willing
to take action on the political issues
of the day like the students are doing
today about the cut because what's
happening in the public in our public
university is it's slowly and
torturously being privatized and you
know I don't have any great love for the
old Latin American Studies programs
because you know they were started after
the Cuban Revolution funded by Ford and
Rockefeller to you know to prevent other
resolutions and a Latin American Studies
Association began with a quorum
membership of a lot of the State
Department people who were out there to
use the Alliance for Progress to prevent
other Cubans so today the Latin American
Studies Association is doing some
is changing in very important ways but
it's also a reflection of the changing
political process in Latin America which
is no longer under the complete hegemony
of the United States and and this is a
you know until a few years ago there
were the Lhasa forum which is the the
magazine was all English and now it's
multilingual the these are expressions
of some some grassroots changes that are
I think very important but they're going
against the current and and in the
United States it's the u.s. is more like
a fortress that's closing its walls
closing to protect its dominant cultural
culture economy and and and losing power
and influence around the world so I this
is the environment in which we're
operating so I'm actually optimistic
that in some way that that we will get
out of this in the US we're going we're
facing some very frightening days and
dangerous days as I see the university
being militarized our public schools
being taken over by police taking kids
away in handcuffs this is this is a
serious threat to everything that this
you know the democratic process that we
are supposed to have been committed to
thank you um we are unfortunately out of
time so um I'm going to ask the
panelists if they have anything else to
say that's 30 seconds or less Tom and
God is 30 seconds and we'll will end
there there I know there are some really
important questions that continue to
need to be raised and I think that these
are really important conversations we're
having still have the panelists have any
I think that they sort of felt with an
incomplete thought that they wanted to
they do have a process and I mean no
disrespect to you for that today's and
has me alireza I just wonder if you
could ask your question so can I give
her my 30 seconds or sure is your yield
your time lotsa work like plus of Mexico
you know but it was appropriated so
that's good so my question is um it
seems that transnationalism is
restructuring globally locally at all
levels and a lot a lot a lot of scales
so um in terms of class race and gender
and I would like you to respond how that
restructuring is going to inform our
action I work at the personal level at
the job at the education at the academia
a housing at the level of rice and the
level that you want to respond thank
thank you okay yes
atena kind of a pretty broad so
maybe it's a thought for next time we
all get together but it's really that
question of the the bilateral closer to
fly lateral conversation and really
thinking about what would a conversation
be or what should the conversation be
between Latino Studies and African
American Studies an Asian American
Studies Native American Studies because
it's happening on the ground so how are
we thinking about it academically how
are you thinking about it pedagogically
really putting different multi
transnational groups into conversation
with each other thank you thank you um i
guess if there any response brief
responses to those issues that were
raised no you just my face that just
kidding no be good yes I mean how can I
said yeah absolutely yeah I agree yeah I
think I was an excellent no.10 Don thank
you so much oh just I think there is one
forum I'll just mention you you all know
the world social forum is one of the
most important forums i think for
carrying on those discussions and
dialogues and if you've participated in
any one of them you know how difficult
those dialogues can be which just is the
challenge that we face and I and I
should add that Latinos and planning is
meant to be a forum to to discuss these
issues and connect theory and in
practice in fact some of us who've
spoken in the past two days are working
together on a book that deals with some
of these issues and in terms of the
dialogues I know that Athena's implying
is one of several population divisions
within the American Planning Association
and Latinos and plan is working very
closely with planning in the black
community division it's reaching out to
other divisions such as indigenous
applying networking but one example is
in the conference the
tional conference in New Orleans there's
going to be a discussion about race and
planning related to because as we know
in New Orleans has been an increase in
in Latinos since Hurricane Katrina so
I'd encourage every all of you who are
interested in planning practice and and
having a transformative effect on
planners to be involved with Latinos and
planning thank you well actually the the
conference is from eight April 10 to 13
the plan of black community is actually
doing a conference prior to the national
conference so it's whatever the two days
before then going to happen and Latinos
implant always does a tour of the Latino
neighborhood and whatever city so if
you're down in New Orleans good you know
please join us on the tour thank you I
think we'll end there I just want to say
this has been a really wonderful
conference and in a really personal note
I think it's really important to thank
lata this is the first time in my long
personal history of Columbia University
in my history as a student here at
Columbia that these doors have been
opened and these questions have been
raised so I think it's really important
to acknowledge that thang